หนึ่งในด้านที่ quantum computing อาจช่วยพัฒนา machine learning ได้
คือเรื่องของ kernel function หรือ
kernel matrix ลองมาดูกันว่ามันคืออะไร
และทำไมถึงต้องใช้มัน เราจะทบทวน
สามเรื่องด้วยกัน ทำไม dot product ถึงปรากฏใน machine learning
ทำไมปัญหา machine learning ถึงเกี่ยวข้องกับมิติสูง
และ kernel function คืออะไร
ทบทวนกันก่อนว่า dot product หรือ inner product ของ
เวกเตอร์จริง n มิติ a
และ b นั้นได้จากผลคูณของขนาดของ a
กับขนาดของ b และโคไซน์ของมุม theta
ระหว่างทั้งสอง ซึ่งเทียบเท่ากับการคูณ
แต่ละองค์ประกอบของ a กับองค์ประกอบที่ตรงกันของ
b แล้วบวกกัน สังเกตว่าถ้าเวกเตอร์
เกือบจะตั้งฉากกัน เช่น a
มีองค์ประกอบเป็นศูนย์ตรงที่ b มีค่ามาก
dot product จะมีค่าน้อย ซึ่งเทียบได้กับ
theta ที่เข้าใกล้ pi หารสอง
ในทำนองเดียวกัน ถ้า a มีองค์ประกอบติดลบในขณะที่ b
มีองค์ประกอบเป็นบวก
หมายความว่าเวกเตอร์ชี้ไปใน
ทิศทางตรงข้ามกันเกือบสมบูรณ์
และ theta ใกล้เคียง pi
ผลของ dot product ก็จะ
ติดลบ สุดท้าย ถ้า a มีองค์ประกอบค่ามากในขณะที่ b
ก็มีองค์ประกอบค่ามากในเครื่องหมายเดียวกัน
คือเวกเตอร์เกือบขนานกัน และ theta ใกล้ศูนย์
dot product จะมีค่ามาก
และเป็นบวก จึงสมเหตุสมผลมากที่ dot product
จะเป็นตัววัดความคล้ายกันที่มีประโยชน์
ระหว่างจุดข้อมูล แต่ข้อมูล n มิติไม่ใช่ทุกชุด
ที่แยกออกจากกันได้ง่ายด้วยการตัดใน n-1
มิติ ไม่ว่าจะเป็นเส้น
ระนาบ หรือไฮเปอร์เพลน เมื่อข้อมูลแยกกันได้ไม่ดี
ใน n มิติ เราสามารถฝังจุดข้อมูล
ลงในมิติที่สูงกว่า สมมติว่า m มิติ โดยที่ m
มากกว่า n วิธีนี้เรียกว่า feature mapping
มักเขียนแทนด้วย x ไปยัง phi(x) โดยที่
phi(x) คือการ mapping จากจำนวนจริง n มิติ ไปยัง
จำนวนจริง m มิติ
มองภาพได้ง่ายที่สุดเมื่อ
โค้งข้อมูลหนึ่งมิติขึ้นไปใน
สองมิติ หรือนำข้อมูลสองมิติ
ฝังลงในสามมิติ
แต่ในทางปฏิบัติ เรามักฝังข้อมูลในปริภูมิที่มีหลักพัน
หรือแม้แต่หลักล้านมิติ
dot product ของเวกเตอร์สามมิติเทียบกับ dot product
ของเวกเตอร์สองมิตินั้นต่างกันแค่เล็กน้อย
แต่ dot product ของเวกเตอร์ล้านมิติ
นั้นยากเกินจะคำนวณได้จริง
เพื่อนำไปใช้กับชุดข้อมูลขนาดใหญ่
คนจึงคิดวิธีแก้ปัญหาอย่างชาญฉลาดขึ้นมา
จะเป็นอย่างไรถ้าใช้การ projection
ไปยังมิติสูงกว่าในรูปแบบที่เฉพาะเจาะจงมาก
ทำให้ dot product ของเวกเตอร์ใน
มิติสูงกว่า เป็นฟังก์ชันง่ายๆ ของ
เวกเตอร์มิติต่ำกว่า นั่นคือหาการ mapping
จากข้อมูล x ไปยัง phi(x) มิติสูงกว่า
ให้ inner product ใน
feature space เท่ากับ
ฟังก์ชันง่ายๆ ในข้อมูลมิติต่ำกว่า
ฟังก์ชัน k นี้เรียกว่า kernel function
ในอุดมคติ เราต้องการให้ kernel function นี้
เป็นฟังก์ชันของ inner product
มิติต่ำกว่าเอง ซึ่งจะทำให้ได้
ข้อดีทั้งสองอย่าง feature space มิติสูงมาก
แต่คำนวณ inner product ได้ง่ายและรวดเร็ว
มองแวบแรกอาจยังไม่
ชัดเจนว่าทำได้จริงหรือเปล่า ลองดู
ตัวอย่างง่ายๆ ในมิติต่ำมาก
พิจารณา feature mapping นี้ มันแปลง
เวกเตอร์สามมิติไปยัง
ปริภูมิเก้ามิติ ปรากฏว่า
inner product ของ feature space เก้ามิติที่ถูก mapping แล้ว
ก็แค่ inner product ใน original
3D space ยกกำลังสอง ดังนั้น inner product
ของปริภูมิที่ถูก mapping ด้วยฟังก์ชัน phi
จะต้องคำนวณ
เก้าพิกัดของ
เวกเตอร์แรก และอีกเก้าของ
เวกเตอร์ที่สอง แล้วค่อยคำนวณ inner product ซึ่ง
ต้องคูณอีกเก้าครั้งแล้วบวก
รวมแล้วใช้ถึงยี่สิบแปดขั้นตอน
ในขณะที่ kernel function ต้องการแค่สามการคูณ
และบวกสองครั้ง รวมแค่สี่ขั้นตอนเท่านั้น
นั่นคือสำหรับการ mapping จุดข้อมูลสามมิติ
ไปยัง feature space เก้ามิติ
เห็นได้ชัดว่าวิธีนี้ได้เปรียบมากแค่ไหน
สำหรับปริภูมิขนาดใหญ่มากๆ
kernel function โดยทั่วไปเป็นฟังก์ชันต่อเนื่อง
ที่ใช้กับเวกเตอร์ใดก็ได้ในชุดข้อมูล
แต่เราใช้ kernel function โดยดึง
จุดข้อมูลเป็นคู่ๆ จากชุดข้อมูล
มาเป็นอาร์กิวเมนต์ การใช้ kernel function กับ
จุดข้อมูลทุกคู่ในชุด
จะได้เมทริกซ์สมมาตรที่เรียกว่า kernel
matrix ชนิดของ kernel function ที่เลือกใช้ขึ้นอยู่กับ
ลักษณะของปัญหา สรุปแล้ว
การอธิบายความคล้ายกันของเวกเตอร์ในชุดข้อมูล
มักต้องใช้ inner product และ inner product ใน
feature space มิติสูงมากนั้นคำนวณแพง
เราจึงใช้ feature mapping ที่สอดคล้อง
กับ kernel function พิเศษบางอย่าง
เพื่อให้การคำนวณมีประสิทธิภาพมากขึ้น
แต่การจำกัดตัวเองอยู่กับ kernel function พิเศษ
ก็จำกัดประเภทของการ mapping ไปยัง feature space ที่
ทำได้อย่างมีประสิทธิภาพ ซึ่ง
อาจทำให้แยกข้อมูลได้ไม่ดีนัก
ถ้ามีวิธีอื่นก็คงดี
นี่แหละคือที่มาของ quantum computing
การ mapping ไปยัง feature space มิติสูงมากที่สอดคล้อง
กับ kernel function สามารถทำได้
บน quantum computer ใน quantum kernel estimator
kernel matrix k ถูกคำนวณ
และจากนั้น classical machine learning algorithm สามารถ
นำไปใช้งานได้ โดยโหลดจุดข้อมูล x1
ทำการ mapping แล้วโหลด
x2 อีกตัว
แล้ว mapping เช่นกัน เนื่องจาก inner product ของสอง quantum state
เชื่อมโยงกับความน่าจะเป็นในการวัด
เราจึงประมาณ inner product ของข้อมูลที่ถูก mapping ทั้งสอง
ได้จากการวัด circuit ผลลัพธ์ซ้ำๆ หลายครั้ง
ใน circuit นี้ circuit ของเรา
จึงบอก inner product ได้
ใน high-dimensional space ที่ circuit จำลองได้
โดยไม่ต้องคำนวณ inner product หรือ
kernel function แบบ classical เลย มีวิธีมากมายใน
การปรับแต่งและพัฒนาวิธีเหล่านี้
และแน่นอนว่ายังมีวิธีใหม่ๆ ที่ถูกเสนอ
และทดสอบอยู่เสมอ หวังว่า
ภาพรวมนี้จะเป็นประโยชน์ในการทำความเข้าใจ
การประยุกต์ใช้ quantum computing
กับวิธี machine learning
โดยเฉพาะวิธีที่เกี่ยวข้องกับ kernel